[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning James how are you feeling
wait what it's perfectly normal to feel
confused you just spent 120 years in
suspended animation what it's okay James
Jim just breathe
everything is okay you're a passenger on
the starship Avalon the Homestead
company's premier in two stellar
Starliner we've nearly completed the
voyage from Earth to your new home
the colony world of home step to a new
world a fresh start
room to grow the Avalon is on final
approach for the next four months you'll
enjoy space travel at its most luxurious
food fun friends friends that's right
Jim the ID band on your wrist is your
key to the wonders of the Avalon you're
in perfect health Jim let's get you to
your cabin where you can get some rest
you may be experiencing post hibernation
sickness you're adorable illuminate for
you welcome to your cabin your home
until we make landfall over the next
four months you'll prepare for your new
life on homestead to meet your fellow
passengers take skill building classes
and learn about colonial living you've
been assigned to learning group
thirty-eight for passengers with
engineering and technical trade skills
please scan your ID to confirm luggage
delivery Jim please scan your ID 8 to
confirm luggage delivery to help you
recover from hibernation be sure to
drink plenty of fluids enjoy the rest of
your voyage on the Avalon a homestead
company starship good morning one at all
it's a beautiful morning here on the
starship Avalon whatever you do don't
get homesick get homestead let's start
things off with one of my favorites back
on earth
just owning this opponent Jim you got a
cool jacket
[Music]
hello passengers will you all please
take a seat
welcome learning group 38 your
introduction to colonial life earth is a
prosperous planet the cradle of
civilization but for many it's also
overpopulated overpriced overrated
I'm sorry I think I may be in lessons
till the end please sir the colonies
offer an alternative a better plan well
or I'll be over there's no colony more
beautiful than homestead to the jewel of
the occupied world where is everybody
we are all on the starship Avalon but
I'm the only one here there are 5000
passengers and 258 crew members so why
am I alone we're all in this together
[Music]
anybody here hello
[Music]
please buckle up and secure any loose
items this elevator will experience a
momentary lapse in gravity
Grand Concourse hello welcome to the
Grand Concourse aboard the Avalon can I
help you I need to talk to a person a
real live person please what sort of
person personal trainer travel planner
therapist I don't know somebody in
charge the ship steward handles
passenger affairs it's on level 3 of the
Grand Concourse thank you happy to help
not good
hello who's flying the ship the flight
crew the captain with a pilot the chief
heavy I want to summon speak to the
captain the captain rarely handles
passenger it's an emergency
please the captain is usually found on
the bridge in the command rank
[Music]
[Music]